auf 70.000 quadratmetern alles schrott
über 2500 autos in der nähe von hamburg
einer der größten europas
kasami sie aber ist hier jeder tag
anders ein riesiger mikrokosmos der nach
eigenen regeln funktioniert das ist
einfach ein brot an die männer steht
hier stehen lauter mittelklassewagen
alles diese und kaum zu glauben alle
noch fahrtüchtig so wie dieser der
besitzer bringt seinen vw passat diesel
zum verschrotten
wegen des großen diesel ab gaspedals in
deutschland ist der wagen jetzt nur noch
1000 euro wert dank abwrackprämie
bekommt er aber viel mehr noch 7000 euro
das eigene fahrzeug was auch
funktioniert auch frühstück und aber
dadurch dass mir seiten leasing auto
geholt habe er jetzt weg ist privat
alles vom schrottplatz betreiber bekommt
er dazu noch geld für die ersatzteile da
gibt es 100 euro schein der musik essen
gehen einmal bis maximal 10.000 euro
rabatt geben einige autokonzerne wenn
diese besitzer ihr altes auto
verschrotten lassen und sich ein neues
umweltfreundlicheres fahrzeug kaufen
alles an die fahrzeuge die noch nicht
dran sind zum zum verschrotten und auch
so ein auto hätten ein bisschen gehalten
aber was im moment verschrottet wird
aufgrund dieser prämie die dann
versprochen auch gezahlt wird
das angebot ist verlockend da wird man
halt schwach
wegen der sogenannten umweltprämie
landen in der recycling werkstatt nicht
nur kaputte autos sondern immer mehr gut
erhaltene wie dieser ein fahrtüchtiger
vw diesel baujahr 2006 einzelteile wie
der motor landen im verkauf immerhin sie
werden recycelt nicht alles landet auf
dem müll
dass du ganz schön weh weil so ein
fahrzeug der hat 47 tausend kilometer
runter der ist so sauber natürlich der
könnte noch einige jahre auf der straße
fahren also der ist noch komplett in
schuss ressourcenschonend ist das nicht
gerade nach der werkstatt übernimmt der
kollege die fahrzeuge
auch brauchbare reifen gehen in den
wiederverkauf dann legt salesianer wie
er sagt das auto trocken altöl rest
benzin scheiben und kühlflüssigkeit
alles wird enthüllt
auch die batterien werden getrennt
und mit dem riesen kneifer schneidet er
die katalysatoren ab das bringt auch
noch ein paar
[Musik]
erst jetzt kommen die autos auf den
schrottplatz bereit für die hobby
schrauber 500 von ihnen zieht es jeden
tag hierher für die ersatzteile bezahlen
sie hier etwa ein viertel des neupreises
[Gelächter]
über 10.000 teile hat ein auto das
passende für sein modell zu finden kann
stunden dauern
das gute stück war den fahrzeughalter
den tempomat ausgebaut da ja einige
autos gleich sind ja ich schraube privat
gern an autos sehr viel und fans einfach
nur schade war hier sind wirklich gute
teile noch bei elf autos besitzt der
deutsche durchschnittlich in seinem
leben
dabei ist die herstellung
ressourcenintensiv das ausschlachten
verbessert die umweltbilanz immerhin ein
wenig
[Musik]
am ende des tages ist auch der
fahrtüchtige weiße vw
auseinandergeschraubt bereit für den
schrottplatz
den rest erledigen die hobby schrauber
drei monate dann ist er so zerfleddert
dass er in der metall- presse landet
bund eingeschmolzen wird
[Musik]